hi this is kim from khan academy and
today we're learning more about what i
like to call the case of the midnight
judges marbury versus madison this case
was decided in 1803 and it established
the principle of judicial review
that the supreme court has the power to
review the constitutionality of acts
made by congress or the president and
overturn those actions that it judges to
be inconsistent with the constitution to
learn more about marbury versus madison
i sought out the help of two experts
michael clarman is a legal historian and
the kirkland and ellis professor of law
at harvard law school kevin walsh is a
professor of law at the university of
richmond law school
so professor walsh can you tell us a
little bit about what was happening in
this case can you set the stage
sure you're right the case wasn't
decided until 1803 but to understand
where it came from you really have to go
back to the election of 1800 and this
election pitted john adams the incumbent
federalist president against his former
vice president thomas jefferson a
democratic republican
and
long story short
jefferson ended up being president and
we've skipped a lot of really
interesting things there but jefferson
ultimately won
the federalists who controlled congress
seeing what was happening made a present
for the incoming administration in in
the form of some laws that created some
new judgeships so some new federal
judges as well as some justices of the
peace in
the district of columbia and then they
proceeded to stuff those offices with
loyal federalists and these were people
like
william marbury who was granted a
commission as justice of the peace in
d.c
marbury was appointed by the federalist
president the outgoing federalist
president john adams to be a justice of
the peace in washington d.c
but john marshall who was both secretary
of state and chief justice of the united
states under john adams he didn't have a
chance to deliver the commission because
these were midnight judges who were
appointed almost at the last minute as
the adams administration was going out
the door
so the commission for marbury was still
sitting on the desk
of the new secretary of state
james madison when the jefferson
administration took over
and the jeffersonians were outraged by
what they saw as an effort to pack the
judiciary by the outgoing administration
so they were refusing to deliver the
commission marbury wants his commission
so he brings a lawsuit in the united
states supreme court demanding that
secretary of state james madison deliver
the commission to him and that's what
leads to the case marbury versus madison
so really this is a case about
uh some men trying to get the jobs that
president adams had appointed them to
but that they weren't able to get
because president jefferson and his
administration refused to
deliver the piece of paper entitling
them to actually take the job very
interesting so this election of 1800 i
think is very significant
in american history because
it was the first
peaceful transfer of power between two
political parties the federalists kind
of led by john adams who had this
stronger central government as one of
their core ideals and then the
anti-federalists or democratic
republicans led by
madison and jefferson who wanted a
weaker central government more power to
the states
so i think it's
one of the coolest things in american
history that
a political party voluntarily gave up
power like when else in the history of
the world did a ruling party just say ah
you know what now our enemies can rule
but there's also this political fallout
from this transfer of power between
parties
and this is the first time that the
jeffersonian republicans are going to be
able to take control of the national
government and the federalists the
outgoing adams administration are
horrified by this they think of
jefferson as an anarchist an atheist
they accused him during the campaign of
being miscegenator they allege it turns
out correctly that he sleeps with his
slaves
they allege that in new england he'll be
stealing their bibles if elected and the
jeffersonians don't think much better of
john adams they think he wants to be a
king he nearly got the country into an
unnecessary war with france so there's
tremendous political animosity neither
side really sees the opposite side as
the loyal political opposition
and then there's personal acrimony as
well thomas jefferson and john marshall
both from virginia are distant cousins
they hate each other
john marshall certainly didn't think
jefferson ought to be elected president
in 1800 and jefferson thinks that john
marshall as chief justice is trying to
undermine
the federal republic through his
nationalist rulings on the supreme court
well it wasn't a pretty transfer
john adams left uh in a huff the morning
that jefferson was going to be
inaugurated
but it was as you say it was a peaceful
transition but the thing is is a lot of
the issues that come with transferring
power from one political party to
another
these were new issues for
the country
and understandably the jefferson
administration resented
the federalist attempt to put their
loyalists into the judiciary the
jeffersonians have won the presidential
election
they've won the congressional elections
by even more the only branch of the
federal government still controlled by
the federalists
is the judiciary and now they're packing
the judiciary they're creating 16 new
federal court of appeals judges 42 new
justices of the peace they're actually
diminishing the size of the supreme
court from six to five so as to deprive
jefferson of an opportunity to
appoint a new justice for one of those
who is retiring uh this is outrageous
and jefferson also thinks it's
outrageous that marbury has filed a suit
in the supreme court and has asked the
supreme court to order the president of
the united states to do something which
jefferson thinks is a violation of the
separation of powers all right so
william marbury is one of these judges
that john adams had appointed in the
midnight hour he decides to sue and this
is
directly to the supreme court right
because it's in the supreme court's
original jurisdiction
okay so he sues directly in the supreme
court right now we we think of the
supreme court generally as a court that
hears appeals right usually you don't go
there in the first instance but as we
said this was a new thing and it was
also new to be suing the executive
branch so it makes sense if you think
about it if you're going after the
president and the president secretary of
state to go directly to
uh the supreme court uh marbury brought
the suit in the supreme court but the
question in the case is whether
the supreme court can hear this within
its constitutional
original jurisdiction so
under the article three of the
constitution at least as john marshall
chooses to interpret it in marbury
versus madison this particular case
can't be in the supreme court's original
jurisdiction it could only be filed
somewhere else and then appealed to the
supreme court so john marshall is a
pretty big figure in the history of the
supreme court can you tell us just a
little bit more about who he is and why
he's so important
sure he is still the longest serving
chief justice john marshall was chief
justice from 1801 to 1835.
he was appointed by president adams in
early 1801 uh this was one of the
final acts of adam's administration and
he went on to say that it was the
proudest thing he had done for the
american people
marshall was a federalist from virginia
so this made him a little bit odd
because the leading political figures
in virginia were democratic republicans
but
marshall had been a soldier in the
continental army
he was at valley forge with washington
and with hamilton and his experiences
under the continental congress and under
the articles of confederation and then
later serving in state government in
virginia
made him realize that we needed a much
stronger
national government and that's what
turned him into a federalist so he was
really in the mold of
washington and hamilton and so
this
put him at odds
with the new president jefferson when
jefferson took office
nevertheless over the course of the
three and a half decades that he was on
the supreme court
marshall gained a reputation for being
above politics above party and he was
really successful in bringing the court
together
as an institution
to speak usually with one voice
for the constitution so his great
success was to identify his himself with
the court
to identify the court with the
constitution and to identify the
constitution with the people
alright so marbury
sues for his
commission as a federal judge
and then marshall and the supreme court
are tasked with this issue of figuring
out whether
marbury should get his commission or not
so can you take us through
marshall's thinking how did he reason
his way to the answer in this case
so there are two different dimensions to
marshall's thinking one is the dimension
of a lawyer and the other is the
dimension of a political strategist
marshall understands that if he issues
an order to the jefferson administration
to deliver the commission he will be
defied he knows that almost to a
certainty
james madison has refused even to show
up in court in response to an order to
show cause why a writ of mandamus should
not be issued so mandamus is
from the same root as mandatory or
mandate right it's an order and here the
issue was did the judiciary have the
power using this rid of mandamus to
order the secretary of state to do
something so marshall has to figure out
what can he do that isn't going to make
the court look hopelessly weak if he
just says there's no jurisdiction then
people are going to think he's supine
and he's afraid to challenge the
president but if he orders the president
to deliver the commission which is what
he'd like to do he knows jefferson will
defy him and he has no authority he has
no uh enforcement capacity so then the
court will just look impotent so what he
wants to do instead is he wants to act
by indirection the first thing he says
is the president's not above the law the
president can be mandators the second
thing he says is in this particular case
a writ of mandamus would be the
appropriate remedy but the third thing
he says is i have to ask whether i have
jurisdiction in this case
the problem is the list of cases in the
constitution that can be heard by the
supreme court in its original
jurisdiction did not include cases like
marbury's so this was a problem because
congress had passed a law purportedly
telling the supreme court that it could
hear cases like this ah okay that's what
marbury was relying on
right he didn't
he wasn't just thinking oh i'm going to
go to the biggest court in the country
he was relying on a federal statute that
seemed to give the court jurisdiction
but marshall said that statute conflicts
with what the constitution says it goes
beyond the limits set for this court in
the constitution
and when you have a conflict between the
constitution
and a federal law or any law
the constitution wins
right so this is the principle
that has been called judicial review the
idea is you have to review the laws to
make sure that they comply with the
constitution and if a law is
unconstitutional it can't be enforced by
the supreme court
so it's a long way of saying that
marbury lost
because the court didn't have
jurisdiction
the court didn't have jurisdiction
because the law that said it had
jurisdiction
was unconstitutional
wow okay so there's a lot going on here
but one of the big takeaways is
this notion of judicial review or the
idea that the constitution wins
and it's up to the supreme court to
decide whether that's the case
can you talk more about
the
effects of judicial review how does it
check the power of the other branches of
government
in order for a law to be enforced
against anybody
all three branches of the government
have to have taken some kind of action
so congress had to have a pass to law
and the president has to sign it
then the law has to be enforced against
somebody in a way that gives rise to a
legal case
and then the judiciary gets the final
word in that legal case as to whether
the law is constitutional so the one way
that judicial review operates as a check
on the president and the executive
is providing a backstop against the
enforcement of unconstitutional laws
so
when the courts strike down president
trump's travel ban that's judicial
review or when the supreme court said
uh president truman exceeded his
authority in ordering the seizure of the
steel mills during the korean war that's
judicial review or when the supreme
court recently almost struck down the
affordable care act that would be an
exercise of judicial review interesting
so
this case and perhaps just
marshall as chief justice in general
made the court i think much more
powerful than it had been do you think
this
new power for the court or expansion of
power for the court would have surprised
the framers
at the philadelphia convention
more of the framers spoke in favor of
judicial review than against but the
issue didn't come up very much there
wasn't that concerted a discussion of it
and they neglected to explicitly
authorize the practice in the
constitution which was kind of an
oversight it's just not a subject they
spent a great deal of time talking about
and even to the extent they believed in
judicial review they probably didn't
think the practice would be anywhere
near as extensive as it's become over
the course of american history the
supreme court just wasn't that powerful
an institution in 1803 and the fact that
it was declaring the exodus the power of
judicial review but then was declining
to exercise it in marbury is very
revealing of how lacking in power the
court was
this was
the first time that the supreme court
exercised this power of judicial review
and it is something that everyone agrees
a power that everyone agrees that the
supreme court
has and it's a big awesome power and so
it affects us because we're still
arguing over
how that power should be exercised and
that is an argument worth having
so we learned that far from simply being
a case about one man's commission
getting lost in the mail marbury versus
madison tested whether the president or
congress was above the law in the united
states chief justice john marshall's
answer was emphatically no and the
decision in this case established an
essential precedent for the supreme
court the power of judicial review to
learn more about marbury versus madison
check out the national constitution
center's interactive constitution and
khan academy's resources on u.s
government and politics